♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE UPDATES FOR
YOU IN A MOMENT ON THE NEW FBI
CENSORSHIP SCANDAL, THE CIA'S
SCANDAL IN THE KENNEDY
ASSASSINATION 59 YEARS AGO WHICH
IS NOW CONFIRMED, IT'S ALL REAL.
BECAUSE IT'S FRIDAY WE'RE IN A
SENTIMENTAL MOOD WE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY GOODBYE
TO ONE OF OUR ALL-TIME FAVORITE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
MR. ADAM KINZINGER OF ILLINOIS.
HE WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
HOUSE 12 YEARS AGO AND FOR THE
BULK OF HIS TIME IN OFFICE HE
SERVED WITHOUT DISTINCTION IN
VIRTUAL ANONYMITY.
A FEW OF HIS CONSTITUENTS HAD
HEARD OF HIM BUT NONE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN LEARNING MORE.
THEN IN 2018 CAME THE
TRANSFORMATION, THAT WAS THE
YEAR HE TURNED 40 AND THINGS
BEGAN TO CHANGE INSIDE OF HIM.
THE FIRST SIGNS WERE SUBTLE BUT
UNMISTAKABLE, CHOKING UP BUT A
CAR INSURANCE COMMERCIAL OPENING
UP AN INSTAGRAM COMMERCIAL AND
THINK PICTURES OF HIMSELF
WEARING SPANDEX BIKE SHORTS TO
STARBUCKS WITHOUT SHAME AND
SOMETIMES WITH THE FANNY PACK.
BY 2021 HE HAD A FULL-BLOWN CASE
OF MALE MENOPAUSE WITH ALL THE
FAMILIAR SYMPTOMS.
MOOD SWINGS, HOT FLASHES,
CRAVINGS, UNCONTROLLABLE
WEEPING.
A LESSER MAN WOULD HAVE
RETREATED FROM PUBLIC LIFE,
CHOSEN NEW PRONOUNS IN
TRANSITION IN PRIVATE.
HE WANTED OTHER MIDDLE-AGED MEN
TO KNOW THERE IS LIFE AFTER A
HORMONAL IMBALANCE.
HE CAME OUT OF THE CLOSET AS A
WEEPY MAN, WE REMEMBER THE
MOMENT.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED THE DATE TO
BE QUITE AS EMOTIONAL FOR ME AS
IT HAS BEEN.
YOU GUYS HELD.
DEMOCRACIES ARE NOT DEFINED BY
OUR BAD DAYS.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE THE COURAGE
THAT TOOK.
YES, I AM EMOTIONALLY
INCONTINENT.
YES, I AM UTTERLY IRRATIONAL.
NO I WILL NOT BE SILENT.
IN WASHINGTON IT WAS CONSIDERED
DEEPLY INSPIRATIONAL, HERE IS A
MAN WHO HAS NO CONTROL OF
HIMSELF AT ALL SO WE BETTER PUT
HIM IN CHARGE OF IMPORTANT
THINGS.
HE QUICKLY BECAME REGARDED AS AN
ESSENTIAL VOICE ON FOREIGN
POLICY.
WHEN THE WORLD HANGS IN THE
BALANCE YOU WANT A GUY WHO CRIES
A LOT.
HE DEMONSTRATED A REMARKABLE
ABILITY TO MAKE ANY SITUATION ON
THE PLANET NO MATTER HOW COMPLEX
OR WEIGHTY ALL ABOUT HIM,
DIPLOMACY BY NARCISSISM.
HIM HERE HE WAS YESTERDAY ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR IN HIS FINAL EMOTION
LADEN ADDRESS.
>> HISTORY HAS PROVEN AMERICAN
ISOLATION FROM THE WORLD AFFAIRS
IS DANGEROUS.
OVER THE YEARS I HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO LEAD THE EFFORT ON
SUPPORTING AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
IN A WORLD DROWNING IN FAUX
STRONGMEN, ADVOCATING FOR THE
RIGHTS OF SYRIAN MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN TO LIVE WITHOUT
BASHAR AL-ASSAD'S DEATH SQUADS
SHOULD BE POLITICAL, IT'S SIMPLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
ADVOCATING FOR A STRONGER
AMERICAN ASSISTANCE IN UKRAINE
TO COUNTER VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
ILLEGAL INVASION SHOULD BE
POLITICAL, IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO, THE WORLD ACTUALLY
ISN'T COMPLICATED TO.
INFECT THE WORLD IS SIMPLE, IT'S
LIKE AN ORIGINAL MADE-FOR-TV
MOVIE ON LIFETIME WHERE YOU BLEW
THROUGH TWO BAGS OF SKINNY POP
TRYING TO KEEP YOUR TEARS AND
CHECK.
IF HE'S DOING SOMETHING IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY WITH GUNS BY
DEFINITION IT'S "JUST THE RIGHT
THING TO DO."
IN SYRIA, HIS OFTEN EXPRESSED
CONCERN FOR THEIR MEN, WOMEN,
AND CHILDREN IS WHAT MATTERS AND
BECAUSE THAT MATTER SO MUCH HE
HAS PUSHED HARD TO CONTINUE THE
NEOCON PROXY WAR.
RESULT?
SYRIA NOW HAS NO ECONOMY LEFT
AND THERE'S A MASSIVE CHOLERA
OUTBREAK IN PROGRESS, MEN,
WOMEN, CHILDREN ARE DYING IN
HUGE NUMBERS BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
SAME IN UKRAINE, HE MADE THAT
CLEAR THE OTHER DAY WHEN HE
RESPONDED PERSONALLY TO A
TWITTER ACCOUNT CALLED CAT TURD.
THE OTHER DAY THEY POSTED A MEME
THAT SEEMS TO MOCK THE COLORS OF
THE UKRAINIAN FLAG, COLORS THAT
ARE SACRED TO ADAM KINZINGER AND
EVERY OTHER APATHETIC SOCCER MOM
IN THE MID-40s, YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW OFFENSIVE THAT WAS
IT WAS LIKE TELLING AN OFF-COLOR
JOKE ABOUT MEGHAN MARKLE -- IT
COULD NOT STAND.
ALONE AND BATTLING DEBILITATING
HOT FLASHES IN HIS KITCHEN
FIGHTING THE URGE TO OPEN
ANOTHER BAG OF CHIPS AHOY!, HE
FOUGHT BACK -- LITERAL EVIL HE
WROTE IN A LATE-NIGHT RESPONSE
TO CAT TURD.
IF I MET YOU IN PERSON IT WOULD
NOT END WELL FOR YOU.
HEAR THAT, CAP TURD?
IT WILL NOT END WELL FOR YOU.
THAT'S NOT A PILLOW FIGHT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT, THAT'S A FULL ON
SLAP FIGHT WITH HAIR PULLING.
THIS IS REAL.
YOU BETTER APOLOGIZE.
OUR HEART GOES OUT TO CAT TURD
TONIGHT, HE'S PROBABLY COWERING
IN A LITTER BOX WAITING FOR
ADAM KINZINGER TO SHOW UP WITH
SHARPENED NAILS -- MOCK THE
UKRAINIAN FLAG AND GET
SCRATCHED.
IT'S A TOUGH TOWN.
SPEAKING OF HOW IT WILL ALL END,
HOW IS IT GOING TO END FOR
ADAM KINZINGER?
WE SUSPECT IT WILL END LIKE IT
BEGAN.
IN WEEKS HE WILL BE ANOTHER CNN
CONTRIBUTOR AND NO ONE WILL EVER
SEE HIM AGAIN.
WE WILL NEVER FORGET HIM.
ADAM KINZINGER WILL LIVE
TOGETHER IN OUR HEARTS AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHEN A MAN CAN BE
WHEN HE STOPS TRYING TO BE A MAN
AND UNLEASHES THE EMOTIONALLY
FRAGILE DIVORCED SINGLE MOM
WITHIN.
HAVE ANOTHER GLASS OF CHARDONNAY
ENLISTED TO ME CRY -- HERE IT
IS, ONE LAST TIME.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED TODAY TO BE
QUITE AS EMOTIONAL FOR ME AS IT
HAS BEEN.
BUT YOU GUYS WON.
YOU GUYS HELD.
DEMOCRACIES ARE NOT DEFINED BY
OUR BAD DA